the Joe Rogan experience what is it what
else is exciting for you on the horizon
boxing wise what what are you looking at
I'm anticipating and eagerly awaiting
the return of Manny Pacquiao hmm listen
we can't not talk about Pacquiao when we
talk about the welterweight division
because I mean because he's 40 and he's
not in the news all the time he's not at
press Congress we don't really always
talk about him when he's got a site
fight a fight sign that sometimes in
these conversations we forget yo he's a
world title holder he just dominated a
guy that there's no way at his age he
should have been able to dominate
considering who Keith Thurman was two
years prior before his surgery Pacquiao
could ruin everybody [ __ ] like but what
do you think about do you think that he
would ever step up and fight Terence
Crawford at this stage of his career I
don't think that fight happens for
multiple reasons
I wouldn't suggest it if I was in his
camp also I don't think that any more
than they want to make the spin scrapper
fight do they want to put PAC out in
that kind of harm's way and give top
ranking is being an opportunity to
dethrone him like you know he's with B
Heyman camp now it's the same with Spitz
so that is going to protect him that
he's not gonna have to say whether or
not he really wants a fight but you can
get it Manny Pacquiao inks deal with
paradigm Sports Management who represent
Conor McGregor oh Jesus that's probably
what they're gonna do Manny Pacquiao no
thanks that's probably what the UFC
wants to try to do is well that they
heard you talking around like well just
got posted a half-hour ago
oh [ __ ] while we're talking oh [ __ ] I
gotta tell you I am if that's the thing
all that anticipation and eagerly
awaiting [ __ ] just flew out the way well
here it is an opportunity for Manny
Pacquiao to make a fuckload of money I
mean that's how I look at it I look at
it for many to make a hundred million
bucks
but you'd have to sell the public I mean
they already watch like Mayweather box
circles around them hey they're gonna
sell it of course it's gonna that's why
it's gonna be a hundred be irritated by
every single every single brown penny
that's spent on that book is going to be
my nemesis you know what you're really
gonna be irritated by the people to
think that Connor has a chance what if
what if they give him six months what if
what if he has some what if he fights
Paulie Malignaggi first what I would pay
for Manny Pacquiao vs. either arrow
Spence or Crawford
I would pay for either one of those
fights I would like that we're like
that's what I would like to see I think
wow man he's 40 I mean after the Keith
Thurman fight he has shown that he's
still like a legit world beater you know
and Terence Crawford is the cream of the
crop in my opinion I want to see that
you know would be more exciting exciting
then both of those fights Shawn Porter
oh that's good fight ooh
Manny Pacquiao vs. on Porter would be a
hell of a night of box very good fight -
very good fight - yeah yeah I don't
believe I believe in world champions all
there's way too many of them in every
weight division this [ __ ] like Oh
undefeated fighters are the only ones
that are worth talking about
I bet still if there's one thing I love
about the UFC and MMA culture period is
that losing a fight doesn't mean losing
your whole [ __ ] brand like right if
you go out there comport yourself well
leave it all in the Octagon you live to
fight another day and people still
respect the effort you put forward like
they recognize that if you're fighting
guys at your level you'll win some and
you lose some and hopefully you win more
than you lose and that's how you yeah
become the man but not but losing some
doesn't make you a [ __ ] does it make
you like a bum well I think Manny's kind
of proven that I mean member when Juan
Manuel Marquez put him in a
Orbitz yeah just put it in an orbit
around Jupiter took him four times to do
it but I'll tell you what I said it on
the night too
by the way that is the most electric
boxing atmosphere I've ever been a part
of it never clarifies my entire adult
life they knew when they were singing
that anthem the Mexicans were singing
they're like the Mexican anthem before
the fight and I was sitting there with a
friend of mine also a fellow journalist
Sean's Attell and we were sitting up in
the rafters where he was sitting in the
press row we were sitting like we I
didn't want to be bothered with all the
the yammering that goes on the press row
so I found feats like up above the ring
and when they were singing that and we
look at each other like Oh something is
about to happen here we knew it was a
special night and bro when he knocked
out Manny Pacquiao he should a crowd
surfed right yeah and he never fought
him again that's what's really
interesting I thought had another one
you should never fought anybody again
it's never gonna get ever better than
that night in that moment yeah but he
still always have that forever and
there's something about especially
Latino fighters it's like they almost
kind of have to keep going like all the
greats kept going all the greats Chavez
kept going way past he should have you
know and then you know I mean so so many
of them just keep going they did yeah
Roberto Duran you know kept going
forever
yeah I mean it's an addiction it's a
lifestyle and if you still believe you
can do it like I'm still better than
most of those guys why not keep doing
one more W who doesn't want one more
mm-hmm
yeah mm-hmm yeah so I decided to pick a
career a little bit more longevity no no
physical downside talk right everybody
right into the ground
[Applause]